Усі думали, що я вийду, як скелет.
Але виглядаю добре, бо з дитинства веду здоровий спосіб життя
і в російських в’язницях не припиняв займатися спортом.
Взагалі не курю, і за ґратами на чифір на підсів.
Так іронічно відповідає Олег Сенцов на запитання журналістів про свій зовнішній вигляд.
Каже, що ще просто примушував себе думати лише про світлі речі.
А, як ставало сумно, дивився російське телебачення.
Я вам одразу скажу, що всі вихідні залишався на Кисельові, не пропускаючи.
Тому що там розваг немає. У в’язниці їх замало.
Цирку немає, театру немає, а тут усе показують. Дуже весело.
Зрозуміло, що вірити йому, хоча б одному слову - це неможливо.
Ким треба бути, щоб в це вірити, що має бути в голові.
А так, дивитися на нього, звичайно, кумедно,
тому що це таке задоволення, дещо збочене, але немає інших.
Тому Кисіль - він молодець, звичайно, в цьому плані.
Сенцов дає першу в Україні пресконференцію. Вона тривала понад 2 години.
Фактично це буде поки єдине його та Олександра Кольченка велике інтерв’ю.
Режисер не хоче ходити по телеканалах.
Тема Росії була головною на цій пресконференції.
Сенцов зізнався, що раніше не вірив словам свого знайомого,
який називав Росію "справжнім болотом, в якому нічого не відбувається".
Сенцов упевнився, що це саме так. У Росії такі протести, як в Україні, неможливі.
Я там пробув 5 років. Так, на жаль, це болото для більшості людей.
Зрозуміло, що у мене було спілкування з окремим контингентом.
Але, це такі ж люди, як ми з вами , просто не пощастило, опинилися у в’язниці.
Не треба вважати, що там якісь страшні кримінальники, як показують у кіно.
Просто люди. Просто в’язниця. Більшості росіян взагалі все байдуже. Їх це не хвилює. Їм байдуже.
Хтось затято за Путіна. Але таких небагато. Хтось проти Путіна.
Теж їх небагато. Більшості - просто все одно.
Сенцов відверто сказав, що дуже хотів би, щоб зусилля активістів,
які час від часу попри увесь тиск влади проводять протести, призвели до фундаментальних змін.
Ніхто не зможе спрогнозувати революцію, завдяки якій Володимир Путін піде на пенсію, скажімо так.
Я б його краще в Гаазі побачив, але, можливо, це не вийде. Ми не знаємо, що буде далі.
Я сподіваюся, що в них щось відбудеться і ця країна стане цивілізованою.
Тому що люди, які хочуть нормально жити, там теж є.
Просто їх замало.
Відносно змін, які відбулися в Україні, поки Сенцов сидів у російській в’язниці,
він відповів, що не розібрався ще до кінця.
Запевняє, що з жодним з політиків він не співпрацює
й особисто в політику поки теж не збирається.
Про обмін полоненими між Україною і Росією, про ціну, яку сплатила Україна
у вигляді звільнення з-під варти того ж свідка катастрофи МН17 Володимира Цемаха,
Сенцов сказав, що лише в літаку почув вперше про цю людину.
А щодо зусиль двох українських президентів, аби обмін взагалі відбувся,
Сенцов сказав, що тут нічого не треба розділяти.
І тим більше казати, що Україна якось програла політично.
Наразі з приходом нової влади, у Росії є шанс ці відносини перезавантажити.
Президент Зеленський також робить крок на зустріч.
Я бачу, що він відверто хоче цей конфлікт вирішити без втрати інтересів.
І це правильно. 100 років перемовин краще, ніж один день війни.
Стосовно того, чи хоче Росія миру.
Скільки б вовк не вбирався в овечу шкуру, зуби у нього постійно на місці, не переживайте.
Не вірте в це. Я не вірю.
Сенцов після повернення з полону буде жити у Києві.
Офіс президента має намір придбати житло політв’язням з Криму.
Але за рідний Крим режисер збирається боротися.
Повернутися туди…Ну, лише на танках. Ми поки не можемо.
Ну, знов  таки, не треба сприймати мої слова буквально.
Розумієте, що я маю на увазі.
Олег Сенцов та Олександр Кольченко провели у російських в’язницях майже 5 років.
Олександр збирається пройти повний курс реабілітації
і потім продовжити навчання у Таврійському університеті.
Олег каже, що має намір займатися найчудовішими речами у світі - жити і знімати кіно.
Але головне: він хоче зробити усе, аби в Україну повернули інших - понад 200 українців,
які досі сидять в підвалах Донецька, Луганська, в СІЗО Сімферополя та у російських в’язницях.
А ще Сенцов хоче боротися і за росіян-політв’язнів, які теж є бранцями Кремля.